la famille élargie de la petite amira
réclamait son rapatriement au canada
depuis plus d'un an
son oncle qui vit à toronto nous avait
expliqué l'an dernier qu'il avait
entrepris de nombreuses démarches auprès
des autorités canadiennes sans succès
c'est très dur
je ne sais pas comment va ma petite
nièce physiquement et mentalement je ne
sais pas si quelqu'un veille sur elle si
elle mange correctement
la fillette est née de parents canadiens
dans la zone tenue par les combattants
du groupe ares les états islamiques
ton père sa mère ses frères et soeurs
ont tous été tué sous ses yeux
depuis le printemps 2010 9 la petite
vivaient dans des conditions extrêmes
entassés avec soixante dix mille
personnes ou qu'en à lol dans le
nord-est de la syrie leur droit
dangereux ou le canada ne souhaitait pas
envoyé son personnel répétait le premier
ministre
nous allons continuer de travailler avec
des partenaires à l'international
ah mais la protection et la sécurité de
notre corps diplomatique de nous
travailleurs canadiens à est toujours
une priorité pour nos aujourd'hui le
ministre des affaires étrangères précise
que l'intervention de l'armée canadienne
a été nécessaire pour exfiltrer la
fillette sans donner plus de détails
sa situation elle demandé une réponse
humanitaire du canada et c'est ce que
nous avons fait et je voulais remercier
tous ceux qui ont participé videmment
les forces armées canadiennes tous ceux
qui nous ont aidés à la ramener cette
nouvelle c'était une surprise l'avocat
de la famille demande maintenant que le
canada viennent au secours des dizaines
d'autres ressortissants canadiens
toujours détenus dans ce camp en syrie
si c'était vraiment une question de
sécurité
et si c'était vraiment question d
[Musique]
de n'avoir pas une relation diplomatique
avec la syrie j'espère que le
gouvernement va agir de façon plus vite
le premier ministre répond que le cas
d'amira était exceptionnelle on a
travaillé depuis des mois et des mois
pour élaborer une façon ou en allez
pouvoir la rapatrier
il n'y a pas d'intention de faire
d'autres opérations comme ça pour le
moment
selon des organisations humanitaires sur
place il y aurait 46 canadiens dont une
majorité d'enfants toujours détenus dans
ce camp
plusieurs pays ont déjà rapatrié leurs
ressortissants
des familles dont les pères parfois des
mères avaient choisi de joindre les
rangs du groupe djihadiste aujourd'hui
en déroute
sylvain desjardins radio-canada moyens